non mais
et le ça fait trois fois que je te le
dis tu ne comprends pas où tu jettes
entraîné tout seul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore une fois c'est pas bon comme si
c'était la première fois en jetons à se
tourner encore les filles le font mieux
croit en toi et tu réussiras
[Musique]
ça
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi à
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 22 septembre
2001 trump et yoann xi jingping poutine
rohani macron les 193 chefs d etat
membre de l'onu
entendu au premier jour de leur
assemblée générale des prises de parole
par visioconférence crise du coronavirus
oblige
antonio guterres est ce le chef de
l'organisation a appelé à éviter une
nouvelle guerre froide
le président américain s'en est prise à
la chine qui doit être tenu pour
responsable de la pandémie
pékin a répondu accusant trump de
propager un virus politiques à l'onu le
président français à lui s exprime en ce
moment en france la lutte contre le
coronavirus poursuit en visite en visite
dans un ehpad du loir-et-cher emmanuel
macron appelle les personnes âgées à
redoubler de vigilance face au rebond de
l'épidémie plusieurs grandes villes eux
restreignent déjà les visites au sénat à
la commission d' enquête poursuit elle
ces auditions
est la république en marche dans
l'impasse les démissions se succèdent à
la direction du parti
le numéro deux pierre person et les
députés sacha ollier et aurore bergé du
bureau exécutif ou claquer la porte
ces départs interviennent au lendemain
d'une déroute aux élections législatives
partielles ou les candidats à la
république en marche ont tous échoué au
premier tour nous décrypterons la crise
traversée par le parti présidentiel avec
alexis cool hein ce sera notre rubrique
l'éditeur
l'onu célèbre cette année ses 75 ans
dans un contexte particulier en raison
de la pandémie de locaux vides 19 peu
diplomate donc dans le vaste complexe
des nations unies à new york est les
discours ont été prononcés par les 193
chefs d'états membres par
visioconférence souvent enregistrés et
parmi les prises de paroles marquantes
cet après midi celle du président
américain
et il a été très offensif vis-à-vis de
la chine lors de sa brève allocution de
six minutes alors que nous oeuvrons pour
réaliser cet avenir radieux nous devons
exiger de la nation qui est à l'origine
de ce fléau mondial qu'elle rende des
comptes je veux parler de la chine
lorsque le virus est apparu la chine a
interdit les voyages à l'intérieur du
pays tout en permettant que des vols
quittent la chine bien fait le monde
la chine a condamné l'interdiction de
voyager que j'ai imposé à son pays alors
même que annulé leurs vols intérieurs et
enfermer leurs citoyens chez eux
le gouvernement chinois et
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
est pour ainsi dire contrôlé par la
chine ont prétendu à tort qu'il
n'existait aucune preuve de transmission
entre nos mains plus tard ils ont
prétendu à tort que les personnes
asymptomatiques n'était pas contagieuse
les nations unies doivent tenir la chine
comptable de ses actes nous nous sommes
retirés de l'accord désastreux sur le
nucléaire iranien et avons imposé de
très lourdes sanctions au premier état
au monde à soutenir le terrorisme
nous avons réduit à néant le califat de
l'oeil elle à 100%
nous avons tué son fondateur et
dirigeant al baghdadi et nous avons
éliminé le pire terroriste au monde
qasem soleimani si la chine a rétorqué
par la suite a accusé trump de propager
un virus politiques à l'onu le président
chinois xi jinping a préféré axer son
discours sur la solidarité mondiale face
à la pandémie
face au virus nous devons renforcer la
solidarité et surmonter ensemble cette
épreuve nous devons respecter la science
faire valoir pleinement le rôle ligne
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
et apporter une réponse collective
internationale pour gagner résolument
cette guerre sale in sanitaire à
l'échelle mondiale toute pratique de
politisation et de stigmatisation doit
être rejetée face au virus
nous devons adopter des mesures de
contrôle intégré et régulière nous
devrons champ où je suis rom ou voir de
manière ordonnée la relance de
l'économie et la réouverture des écoles
pour créer de l'emploi relancer
l'économie et rétablir l'ordre et le
dynamisme économique et sociaux et puis
en fin d'après midi le président russe a
notamment souligné la nécessité pour les
cinq membres permanents de l'onu de se
réunir dans un contexte de fragmentation
entre les pays
depuis moscou notre correspondante one
claireaux nous donne plus de précisions
pour commencer vladimir poutine a
rappelé l'importance de l'organisation
des nations unies et sa charte pierre
angulaire des relations internationales
un texte qui garantit la souveraineté
des états et l'égalité entre ces mêmes
états il a loué le rôle du conseil de
sécurité un organisme qui je cite
fonctionne et qui a permis d'éviter
plusieurs conflits dans un second temps
il a longuement évoqué la crise du coc
u19 une crise sanitaire mais aussi socio
économiques qui il a dit prendra du
temps à se résorber
pour tenter d'y remédier le président
russe a fait une proposition la création
d'un espace eurasiatique libre de
sanctions ou les biens de première
nécessité pourraient circuler librement
je porte votre attention sur la
procession proposition russe de création
des couloirs verts qui ne connaissent
pas des barrières pour acheminer des
médicaments des vivres des moyens de
protection qui sont nécessaires pour la
lutte contre la pandémie en général
c'était épuration du commerce
international des barrières des
sanctions illégitime
tout cela pourrait être une bonne base
pour le rétablissement est qu économique
pour la lutte contre le chômage la lire
poutine ensuite souligné la nécessité de
mettre tout le potentiel de l'industrie
pharmaceutique mondiale au service du
développement et de la mise sur le
marché de vaccins
il a fait savoir que la russie qui
dispose de son propre vaccin le spoutnik
v est prête à coopérer avec les pays qui
en feront la demande
enfin le président russe a rappelé la
volonté de la russie de parvenir à une
stabilité stratégique entre les pays
d'où l'importance des traités de
limitation des armements
la priorité c'est la poursuite de
l'accord entre la russie et les etats
unis sur les armes aux offensives qui
expirent en 2021 et nous menons des
discussions avec nos partenaires
américains et nous insistons sur la
nécessité de limiter la portée des
missiles concernés et dé l'année
dernière j'insiste là dessus nous avons
proposé un moratoire sur l'installation
de tels missiles en europe et dans
d'autres zones
tant que les états unis ne serons pas
signataires d'hôtel et pour l'instant
nous n'entendons pas de réponse de la
part des états unis à notre proposition
le discours de vladimir poutine se
voulait rassembleur une intervention
lors de laquelle il a souligné
l'importance des grandes institutions
internationales avec en premier lieu les
nations unies et plus particulièrement
le conseil de sécurité et le président
français manuel macron est en train de
s'exprimer en ce moment même son
allocution devrait se terminer en tête
dans quelques instants et on va tout de
suite retrouvé notre reporter mona a
moulé l'or devant l'elysée mona bonsoir
donc le président a poursuivi son
allocution mais dès à présent qu'est ce
qu'on peut retenir de cette prise de
parole du président
bonsoir olivier plusieurs sujets ont été
abordés lors de ce discours du président
de la république
il a parlé de la libye du liban du mali
ou encore de la chine et de la corée
vous le voyez plusieurs sujets ont été
mentionnés c'était un discours assez
complet un sujet fort pendant ce
discours il a commencé tout d'abord en
parlant de la pandémie
il a expliqué qu'il fallait vivre avec
ce virus écoutez le d'abord je crois en
la science et en la connaissance et
l'humanité vaincre à cette pandémie un
remède sera trouvé mais dans cette
attente dont nul ne sait combien elle
durera chacun d'eux me pays n'aura
d'autre choix que d'apprendre à vivre
avec le virus et le monde devra
apprendre à vivre avec cette nouvelle
réalité qui s'impose à tous révèlent nos
vulnérabilités nous place devant nos
immédiate responsabilité cette nouvelle
réalité mondiale est clair brutale
certainement vertigineuse et nous devons
la regarder sans nous laisser aller au
désespoir ni au découragement mais avec
lucidité
après avoir commencé son discours sur à
la pandémie et l'importance d'apprendre
avis finalement avec ce virus le
président de la république s'est penché
sur les relations internationales
notamment entre est la chine et les
états unis il indique le monde ne doit
pas se résumer à la chine et aux à
l'asie et aux états unis je propose
notamment à de l'écouté il faudra
compter à l'avenir avec ces nouveaux
équilibres qui sont en train de se
définir
il faudra compter sur la force des
bonnes volontés parce que le monde tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui ne peut pas se
résumer à la rivalité entre la chine et
les états unis quel que soit le poids
mondial de ces deux grandes puissances
quel que soit aussi l'histoire qui nous
lie en particulier aux états unis
d'amérique la crise l'effondrement de
nos craintes de nos cadres de
coopération les fragilités que je viens
d'évoquer nous impose de rebâtir un
nouvel ordre et impose à l'europe de
prendre toute sa part de responsabilité
c'est à dire de porter ses valeurs son
goût de l'avenir et de savoir bâtir des
solutions nouvelles
l'appui le discours du président de la
république s'est dirigé vers l'union
européenne il explique il faut rebâtir
un nouvel ordre
grâce à l'union européenne l'importance
et la cohésion de tous ces pays et puis
il a également parlé un petit peu du
moyen-orient du liban notamment
l'importance pour le pays de former un
nouveau gouvernement il
mais qu'il serait toujours à présent et
l écoute pour aider le liban à aller de
l'avant et puis il s'est exprimé
également concernant à la normalisation
des relations entre israël et plusieurs
pays arabes il a félicité ses
normalisation mais il a néanmoins eu eu
un mot pour la palestine écouter la paix
au proche orient reste une nécessité
d'abord pour les israéliens et les
palestiniens mais pour nous tous je me
réjouis qu israël obtiennent la
reconnaissance de nouveaux pays arabes
c'est une reconnaissance légitime c'est
aussi un gage d'espoir pour l'avenir
pour autant une paix juste et durable
nécessite avant tout de retrouver les
voies et moyens d'une négociation
décisive qui permette aux palestiniens
de disposer enfin de leurs droits il n'y
a pas d'alternative à une négociation
courageuse qui nécessitera de s'entendre
sur les questions les plus difficiles
dans le respect des aspirations
légitimes de chacun à une reconnaissance
pleine et entière à la sécurité et à la
souveraineté
je ne crois pas à une paix qui se
construira sur l'hégémonie ou
l'humiliation
quand bien même celles-ci seraient
compensés par de l'argent car nous
savons trop qu'on ne compense pas
l'humiliation d'un peuple par de
l'argent le président de la république a
également eu un mot pour la russie l'a
indiqué qu'il fallait faire toute la
lumière sur l affaire un avanies et
notamment concernant le supposé
empoisonnement de du de alexeï navalni
vous l'avez compris ça a été un discours
complet plusieurs thématiques plusieurs
sujets internationaux vont été mentionné
lors de ce discours axé sur les
relations internationales
multilatéralisme et surtout l'importance
de la coopération entre tous les pays
merci beaucoup mona brousse et précision
mon amour est alors en direct de
l'elysée gestion de la pandémie conflit
réchauffement climatique dans un monde
en pleine mutation
l'onu doit donc faire face à de nouveaux
défis pour les générations futures
on va en parler tout de suite avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales avec nous également
anaïs or s'ils avaient climatologue au
laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement
spécialiste de l'antarctique
jean-christophe gallien géopolitologue
nous a également rejoint bonsoir et
merci à tous les trois d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en direct sur rt france
de nombreux défis donc affrontés pour le
revenu et une alerte cet après-midi
d'antonio goûter res le chef de
l'organisation il a appelé en premier
lieu à éviter une nouvelle guerre froide
claude blanche maison antonio good t rès
il pensait notamment à la rivalité
sino-américaine c'est cela oui bien sûr
je crois que monsieur bouteille est sa
raison le risque est réel et on l'a bien
vu aujourd'hui en écoutant et de
discours du côté américain on a eu
l'impression de voir l'aigle américain
montrer ses griffes et du côté chinois
le dragon chinois rentrait les siennes
alors monsieur trump en effet a accusé
de façon tout à fait frontale la chine
d'avoir infecté le monde entier avec le
kobe de 19 d'avoir empêché l'om est
organisation mondiale de la santé de
réagir à temps et par la même occasion
il a accusé la chine d'infiltrer et
ainsi l'influencé toutes les
organisations internationales
il ya aussi accusé d'être un créateur
technologique et de fossés de manière
insidieuse les relations économiques
internationales
et puis finalement il a dit en concluant
que les états unis
avait dépensé 2500 milliards de dollars
en quatre ans pour leur défense
c'est-à-dire pour renforcer leur armée
ce qui est naturellement colossal et il
est dit la vérité c'est-à-dire nous
sommes le pays le plus puissant du monde
et lorsque nous négocions les accords
bilatéraux et bien c'est une
contribution à la paix du monde alors l
inverse si jean ping s'est montré le
chantre du multilatéralisme
l'apôtre du libéralisme est évidemment a
soutenu toutes les organisations
internationales il a aussi effectivement
souhaité que tous les pays coopèrent
pour redresser l'économie mondiale
frappée de plein fouet par la pandémie
alors jean christophe gallier un bon
coup beaucoup ont souligné aujourd'hui
les relations difficiles entre les états
membres de l'onu il ya également ce
contexte de crise de coronavirus le chef
de l'onu a donné 100 jours à la
communauté internationale pour un cessez
le feu
on imagine les obstacles gigantesque
alors comment vous analysé cette raison
d'espérer d'antonio goûter res est ce
que c'est un voeu pieux est ce que c'est
possible avec les forces de bonne
volonté comme viens de dire emmanuel
macron quel est votre regard
malheureusement un voeu pieux c'est un
album est presque de désespoir
finalement la situation aujourd'hui je
crois que cette maison qui à 75 ans et
n'est plus adapté au monde multipolaire
et à ses volontés puissance relativement
exacerbée qui se combine avec il faut il
faut le dire et c'est assez dans sa
réponse à des temps exponentielle aussi
tout à tout s'est accéléré c'est pas le
coc vie qui finalement qui est un
facteur accélération supplémentaire qui
a changé la donne c'est finalement les
grandes tendances à l'oeuvre qui sont
évidemment cette fracturation cette
fracture du monde entre différents blocs
mais cette fracture elle ne vit que sur
une augmentation exponentielle de la
population des échanges des flux de
communication tout ça participe
d'attentes qui est tout à créer un
certain don très peu sont capables de
devoir au delà finalement du trimestre
voire du semestre qui vient
et donc c'est compliqué pour une vieille
maison comme celle là que de jouer
finalement plutôt les pompiers après des
incendies qui se répètent et qui
finalement sont sains malgré tout trouve
parfois notamment au conseil de sécurité
dès capacités de solutions dont que le
secrétaire général appelle à 100 jours à
une paix globale on peut imaginer
effectivement que c'est un beau message
mais on y croit très peu parce que
encore une fois ça n'est pas la réalité
de ce que vivent les différentes du
monde et ça n'est pas simplement encore
une fois parce qu'il ya des acteurs de
différents blogs qui veulent interagir
et 131 m
les temps ont changé les temps ont
changé et tous les paramètres
aujourd'hui sont des paramètres de
friction des paramètres de tensions il y
a que très peu d'espacé très peu de
géographie très peu de thématiques qui
ne donne pas lieu finalement à des
volontés encore une fois d'en découdre
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
finalement au total malgré ces tensions
extrêmes malgré cette incertitude on a
finalement quelque chose qui se passe
pas si mal et donc le nu dans ce
contexte la quête une maison du commun
qui est une maison on oralement
viendrait
le multilatéralisme tenter de corriger
le monde multipolaire de cette ambition
multipolaire
elle a du mal à agir mais finalement de
temps en temps malgré tout elle pose son
empreinte notamment quand il s'agit de
trouver des solutions des incendies l'om
s a été critiquée mais l'om est travail
certaines actions encore une fois des
forces et les casques bleus sont
toujours là il y a des points positifs
mais évidemment c'est compliqué de faire
face à ces évolutions
anaïs or si jean claude galien viennent
nous dire tout s'est accéléré le
réchauffement climatique également c'est
aussi un cap pour l'onu son chef a parlé
d'un nouveau contrat social et qui doit
assurer la transition vers les énergies
renouvelables pour atteindre l'objectif
de zéro émission net d'ici 2050
c'est un enjeu majeur aujourd'hui pour
pour l'organisation
ah c'est sûr c'est le changement
climatique c'est un accélérateur de
toutes nos difficultés quelque part et
ça touche autre chose est plus basique
de l'existence humaine comme l'accès à
l'eau comme l'agriculture les choses en
main s'est passé comment comprendre
justement que cette question climatique
aujourd'hui elle ne fait pas consensus
on se souvient les états unis s'étaient
retirés des accords de paris sur le
climat nice orci et bien je pense
qu'elle ne fait pas consensus parce que
la solution est difficile c'est un petit
peu comme mon grand père qui à du
diabète et qui mange le gâteau à la
crème fouettée non c'est pas qui sépare
la compo l'iut de la crème si j'étais
quand tu es devant lui il n'a pas
résisté c'est juste aussi simple que ça
en fait c'est juste difficile de prendre
des fientes difficile mais tellement
utile de ne rien faire que pousse la
balle
la personne d'après je pense qu'il faut
pas nécessairement chercher plus loin
dans la difficulté qu'on a à prendre en
main et les enjeux de demain mais quand
même il faudrait que les choses bougent
claude blanchemaison c'est un véritable
enjeu diplomatique cette lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique au fond ou
alors ça passe bien un peu au second
plan pour les différents états non je
crois c'est un véritable enjeu en effet
nous sommes un petit peu au bord du
précipice et je crois que là-dessus tous
les scientifiques sont d'accord
maintenant ce qui se passe c'est que les
politiques et d'ailleurs les diplomates
ont très souvent un langage qui est un
langage politiquement correct sur le
sujet c'est à dire qu'ils adoptent au
qu'ils acceptent les conclusions du
sommet de paris et des sommets qui ont
suivi alors la grande différence c'est
que depuis que monsieur trump et
prévient les états unis monsieur trump
est l'un des premiers à sortir du
politiquement correct et du coup a
dénoncé l'accord a dénoncé d'accord est
effectivement pour son électorat
c'est une bonne chose parce que il peut
dire à jean qui aura sur l'électorat
je ne me laisse pas conter par des
accords internationaux qui imposerait
des contraintes injustifiée à l'économie
américaine et du coup d'autres pays
wolson à rossi est également essayé à un
moment donné effectivement envisage de
ne pas respecter et beaucoup de pays au
bout du compte quel que soit les propos
qu'ils tiennent sur le plan politique ne
respectent pas les contraintes qui
résulte de ses engagements pour limiter
le réchauffement climatique
donc on est là un petit peu dans un jeu
qui relève un petit peu de l'hypocrisie
c'est à dire
la plupart des pays se conforme au
langage du politiquement correct mais
quitte à ne pas complètement appliquée
les les conclusions des directives
desmet de paris les suivantes
alors jean claude galien je vouvoyais
hocher de la tête vous souhaitez réagir
aux propos de claude manche maison
mais je crois que malheureusement c'est
ainsi que c'est un sujet qui
encore une fois un sujet extrêmement
globalisé hyper local et cc lacq c'est
exact moment que nous vivons un moment
où nous voyons bien que le virus nous
dit bien qu'il n'ya pas de local qu'ils
soient à l'abri du global ni du le
global ni même lui est à l'abri des
effets du lauquet alors c'est pas à
l'environnement malheureusement je ne
crois pas que ça soit aujourd'hui on
puisse peut dire l'enjeu géopolitique et
diplomatique majeur je pense
qu'aujourd'hui et la crise de du virus
la film en accéléré cette tendance que
nous voyons depuis la coque de paris
s'est plaint d'indicateurs et dans les
mondes indicateurs montrent qu'au
contraire les marchés que l'ensemble des
facteurs d'investissement notamment sur
le terrain energy ont largement délaissé
le renouvelable pour aller vers le
fossile voir le nucléaire
il ya donc des évolutions qui ne sont
pas de fait au delà des prises et des
incantations politique on voit à
répétition je crois que malheureusement
les peuples ont bien compris et c'est
très difficile ensuite sur le plan
individuel sur le plan encore une fois
du local de faire référence à cette
histoire de diabète dont vous parlez
très justement thaler et de manger wi fi
nalement a tous très envie de manger le
gâteau parce que finalement on voit bien
que au niveau global va les grandes
actions les grands leaders ne sont pas
au rendez vous chacun pour soi il ya
presque même une alliance pour le coup à
fond jusque là une alliance entre là
pour le coup les états unis la chine
l'inde à l'australien semble d'autres
états pour dire mais après tout ça n'est
pas l'enjeu principal nous avons
d'autres chats à fouetter d'autres
bataille prioritaire et nous souhaitons
individuellement pouvoir avoir la qui
dit nous voulons avoir est donc au-delà
des incantations diplomatique et
géopolitique
on est très loin finalement termes
d'actions hormis le local hormis des
choses qui se passent dans les villes
dans les régions pour des stratégies
parfois beaucoup plus ambitieuse on
n'est pas au rendez vous et je crains
malheureusement les quelques mois qui
viennent ne soit pas non plus au rendez
vous malgré la coop à glasgow vous
verrez des incantations mais vous ne
verrez pas des grands actes concrets
parce que le concret manque
effectivement il sort si je rappelle
vous êtes climatologues
vous rejoignez ses propos de
jean-christophe gallien sur cette
question du réchauffement climatique qui
dit oui peut-être très bien dans les
mois à venir il y aura des paroles mais
pour les actes qu'il faudra attendre en
attendant il ya des questions
économiques par exemple qui sont plus
importantes
ça c'est pas un avenir chez les
questions économiques sont plus
importants mais s'il ya un domaine dans
lequel je m'éternise multi l'état marche
super bien c'est justement la science
parce que ce soit court le virus l'a la
recherche d'une solution que ce soit
dans la recherche sur le climat
en fait on est une grande famille
scientifique mondiale et c'est la
coopération qui prime et celle échanges
de savoirs qui prime
et là il ya vraiment pas frontières
sûres comment est-ce qu'on va réussir à
bien comprendre quels sont les enjeux de
demain et savoir quels sont les dangers
auxquels on fait passer comment est-ce
qu'on va y répondre ça c'est quand même
un point positif qui monte et
l'interallié claude blanchou maison je
vous laisse la parole pour conclure sur
la forme de cette rencontre des prises
de parole à distance en raison du
coronavirus finalement et cette formule
est ce que ce n'est pas l'occasion de
cristalliser encore plus les relations
entre les uns et les autres sur ces
différents sujets convient d'évoquer
notamment la question thématiques
si vous êtes un vrai a interrogé le
diplomate que je suis naturellement ce
genre de réunion c'est l'horreur
puisqu'on a sans qu'on aura la fin de la
semaine
193 déclarations plus ou moins longues
juxtaposées sans aucun sans aucun
dialogue
alors ces déclarations sont utiles sont
importantes puisque c'est la position de
chacun des pays à un moment donné avec
l'accent mis sur les points qui
ressemble plus le plus important mais
les autres années
sans coronavirus cette semaine dit à
haut niveau à new york aux nations unies
c'était la semaine de tous les contacts
c'était là que se faisait la vraie
diplomatie c'est à dire qu' il y avait
des négociations
les gens avaient des rencontres
bilatérales aux besoins des rencontres
improvisées et faisait avancer des
projets qui n'étaient pas d'ailleurs des
projets nécessairement à l'ordre du jour
donc ceci est bien l onu en sera privée
cette année puisque le corps d'un virus
fait que que ça n'est pas que ce n'est
pas possible je crois que c'est très
c'est assez grave pour pour pour l'onu
monsieur poutine a proposé qu'il y ait
lorsque la situation sanitaire le
permettra un sommet des cinq dirigeants
des cinq membres permanents du conseil
de sécurité
c'est une proposition d'ailleurs qui
rejoint une proposition française qui
avait déjà été fait dans le passé
j'imagine que ça dépendra très largement
du résultat des élections américaines du
3 novembre prochain je ne suis pas
certain que monsieur trump soit très
friands de ce genre de réunions avec
monsieur jean ping et avec les autres
merci beaucoup à tous les trois de nous
avoir aidés de décrypter cette assemblée
générale à l'onu notamment sur cette
question du réchauffement climatique
merci à vous claude blanchemaison je
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales merci anaïs or
s'ils avaient climatologue au
laboratoire des sciences et du climat et
de l'environnement et spécialiste de
l'antarctique et merci à vous jean
christophe gallien géopolitologue est
resté avec nous sur rt france dans
quelques instants nous ferons le point
sur la situation sanitaire en france en
visite dans un ehpad du loir-et-cher
emmanuel macron a appelé les personnes
âgées à redoubler de vigilance face au
rebond de l'épidémie puis ce sera à
l'édito d'alexis poulard il reviendra
sur les tensions au sein du parti
présidentiel
avec deux nouvelles démissions
[Musique]
quelle reprise économique pour l'après
qu'ovide 19 à quoi peut-on s'attendre on
a été dans l'oeil du cyclone cet été en
fait ça fait à peu près trente ans que
la croissance structurelle en france
baisse donc elle va continuer à être au
mieux médiocre iv au pire catastrophique
les prévisions que peuvent faire le fmi
ou la deutsche bank
c'est des prévisions au doigt mouillé ça
n'a pas grande valeur si l'état était
capable de relancer l'économie
la france est le pays plus développés du
monde beaucoup de pays était déjà en
récession donc le coville n'a été qu'un
catalyseur en fait de ce qui s'est passé
aucune de l'ue croatie il faut que ceux
qui prennent des risques gagne plus
d'argent que ce qui entraîne pas parler
de croissance comprend toutes les
mesures qu'il faut pour que les
entrepreneurs ne gagne pas d'argent
j'ai un peu pas bien sérieux
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt francs si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française à la situation sanitaire en
france et les derniers chiffres de santé
publique france l' agence annonce plus
de dix mille nouvelles contaminations
aux copies de 19 ans 24 heures soixante
huit personnes sont décédées à l'hôpital
et 651 patients sont en réanimation le
taux de positivité à lui progressé à 6,1
pour cent contre 5,9 pour cent à la
veille dans ce contexte emmanuel macron
a visité un ehpad du loir et cher cet
après midi et il a dit ne pas souhaiter
isolé à nouveau les aînés mais les
appelle à la plus grande vigilance et
pour revenir sur la situation dans ces
établissements
nous sommes avec eux didier sapy il est
directeur de la fédération nationale
avenir et qualité de vie des personnes
âgées didier sapy bonsoir merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
les épate ce sont des confiné mais de
nouvelles restrictions sont peu à peu
imposée manuel macron je le disais ne
souhaite pas confiné à nouveau les plus
vulnérables mais il les appelle à
redoubler de vigilance cela veut dire
quoi très concrètement c'est moins de
visites
ce sont des visites peut-être plus
réglementée avec beaucoup plus deux avec
plus de précaution mais dans certains
cas seulement croient qu'ils font pas
totalement dramatiser la situation dans
nos établissements
il ya aujourd'hui 121 établissements en
france qui sont touchés en ça peut
paraître beaucoup comme ça mais je
rappelle qu'il ya 7000 de près de 7500
établissement sis à kiev à 1,5 pour cent
aujourd'hui qui sont touchés l'objectif
c'est de protéger et de préserver tous
ceux qui ne le sont pas donc c'est une
ce sont ces précautions là qu'il qu'il
convient de prendre il faut que les
familles dont on a besoin dans nos
établissements auprès de leurs parents
auprès de nos personnes âgées
comprennent fassent preuve de
compréhension et d'esprit de
responsabilité par rapport à ça et
accepte un certain nombre de règles de
précaution dans un dans un certain
nombre de cas parce que ces vagues
durant le confinement et aujourd'hui on
va vers en tête dans cette volonté de
les risées c'est ces lieux là c'est pas
la bonne solution vous nous dites
aujourd'hui
ah non surtout pas le président de la
république a raison il singe impact
considérable sur la vie des gens ça y
est la qualité de vie des personnes
âgées lors lors les interactions
sociales qu'elles peuvent avoir
l'isolément le risque d'isolement serait
catastrophique isolement de leur famille
et de toutes leurs relations sociales on
en vue dans un certain nombre de cas des
situations difficiles c'est très
difficile à vivre pour ces personnes qui
ont encore ces familles qui ont encore
ses relations sociales et qu'elles
doivent qu'elles doivent développer
jusqu'au bout bien entendu donc c'est
extrêmement important de ne pas isoler
ces personnes une deuxième vague serait
serait totalement catastrophique bien
entendu et on est confronté bien sûr à
ce dilemme permanent entre protéger nos
résidents protéger les personnes qui
vivent dans nos établissements et les
accompagner au mieux dans leur qualité
de vie dans les derniers mois ou deux
dernières années de leur vie bien
entendu et en ce qui concerne la
réactivité dans les ehpad face par
exemple à une suspicion de 4 coronavirus
comment est-ce que ça se passait ce que
les campagnes de dépistage au sein de
ces établissements sont fréquentes
est-ce qu'il ya moins de délais pour
avoir des résultats annoncent être vrai
point clé aujourd'hui ce sont ce sont
les tests la réactivité en termes
d'organisation dans les établissements
d'agilité de mise en place d'un certain
nombre de mesures organisationnelles
d'appels à des équipes mobiles avec la
coopération des services de l'état tout
ça fonctionne ça fonctionne plutôt bien
sur le territoire
la grosse difficulté ce sont les tests
ce que nous demandons aujourd'hui au
ministère à nos pouvoirs publics c'est
d'organiser mieux ces tests et dès que
nous avons un cadeau qu vide
suspicieux ou avérées dans nos
établissements il faut impérativement
qu'il ya des équipes mobiles qui
viennent dans les établissements pour
tester tous les résidents tous les
salariés dans les 24 heures avec des
résultats des tests dans les 24 heures
ça c'est absolument c'est la priorité
absolue par rapport à ces mesures de
précaution justement aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas pensable d'attendre sept jours
ou neuf jours des résultats de tests
avant de pouvoir prendre des mesures
organisationnelles
la direction de l'établissement doit
savoir le plus vite possible ce qu'il en
est parmi les résidents des ehpad quel
est le moral aujourd'hui quelle est
l'atmosphère et au sein des personnels
aussi comme en vente iront on peut
rappeler qu'il veille sur les personnes
âgées depuis plus de six mois maintenant
vous savez sur les personnes âgées elles
mêmes elles sont plus de 600 milles à
vivre dans nos établissements et c'est
difficile de savoir comment elles vont
tout parce que vous avez six cent mille
situations différentes et les gens
vivent les choses de manière extrêmement
différentes
alors pour les salariés je peux
peut-être plus en parler on a peut-être
plus de retour il est vrai aujourd'hui
qu'on a des vraies difficultés au niveau
des ressources humaines parce que les
salariés ont vécu cette vague ont fait
face avec énormément de courage et et
d'agilité je le disais et aujourd'hui
elles sont fatiguées elles ont passé
l'été les vacances ont pas été si facile
que ça on est dans cette situation de
risque permanent on sait que ça va durer
plusieurs mois
il ya de la peur il ya des craintes il
ya de la fatigue on a des absences aussi
parce que à la moindre suspicion de co
vide il faut isoler les gens c'est
difficile on peut pas laisser des
professionnels intervenir auprès de
personnes extrêmement fragile sans être
sûr qu'elles sont en bonne santé
donc tout ça génère aussi des
difficultés de remplacements des
sous-effectifs on a besoin d'être aidé
là aussi par les pouvoirs publics
d'avoir plus de bras plus de ressources
humaines à très court terme dans nos
établissements
didier sapy pour conclure en quelques
mots emmanuel macron a indiqué que son
objectif est d'être présenté dès le
début de l'année prochaine un projet de
loi sur le grand âge et l'économie lors
de sa visite à cet après midi dans un
ehpad du loir et cher
qu'est ce que vous en attendez mais tous
attend tout ça fait ça fait deux ans
maintenant qu'il l'a annoncé il l'avait
annoncé en juin 2018 pour fin 2010 9
ça fait plusieurs mois qu'on nous
l'annoncent pour fin 2020 on craignait
que il nous annonce un report même d'un
an supplémentaire donc c'est plutôt
rassurant qu'il annonce une autre notre
loin au début de l'année 2000 21
c'est très attendu maintenant il suffit
pas de le dire il faut le faire
ils font vraiment qu'ils le fassent ça
fait des années ça fait des années qu'on
attend ça fait des années que nous avons
des dizaines et des dizaines de rapports
ce sera la loi la prom' probablement la
plus documentée du quinquennat
maintenant il faut agir
on attend de lui qu'il agisse et pas
seulement qu'il le dise maintenant il
faut qu'il le fasse
merci beaucoup didier sapy d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes directeur de la fnac passé la
fédération nationale avenir et qualité
de vie des personnes âgées
alors comment l'exécutif agit-il face à
cette crise sanitaire at il assez
anticipées at il commis des erreurs et
bien pour tenter de répondre à ces
questions une commission denquête au
sénat a été ouverte et les auditions se
poursuivent
florence paris la ministre des armées a
été entendu cet après-midi à et xavier
bertrand ancien ministre des solidarités
et de la santé sous jacques chirac était
lui interrogé ce matin c'est l'actuel
président du conseil régional des hauts
de france
écoutez la réaction des sénateurs de la
commission à son audition mais je les
trouvais quand même très clair très
explicite dans ses positions en tout cas
notamment le fait qu'il ait dit que
brouilla éminemment une question de
volonté
quand on est à la tête du ministère de
la santé mais surtout que si lui il
avait réussi à gagner ses batailles on
va dire contre vers 6 quand il
s'agissait de négocier des budgets c'est
surtout parce que le président de la
république l'avait soutenu sans faille
ça c'était je pense un message envoyé au
gouvernement actuel
l'absence de culture d'évaluation
depuis des décennies dans notre pays et
puis surtout c'est la capacité
d'anticipation d'une triste qui est tout
à fait intéressante pour faire en sorte
qu' on puisse prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour gérer la crise plutôt
que l'administré c'est un peu ce que
j'ai retenu en synthèse de
l'intervention de xavier bertrand
intéressons nous maintenant à la
république en marche la direction du
parti présidentiel est dans la tourmente
elle voit les démissions se succéder
avec notamment celle du numéro deux
pierre person et dans la foulée celle
des députés sacha ollier aurore bergé du
bureau exécutif à des départs au
lendemain d'une débâcle aux élections
législatives partielles ou les candidats
lrm ont tous échoué au premier tour et
pour parler des problèmes auxquels est
confrontée lrm nous sommes avec alexis
poulain c'est notre rubrique l'édito
fois alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france
alors ce week end je le disais encore
une déconvenue électorale pour la
république aux marges dans les
législatives partielles ou les candidats
la république en marge ne sont pas au
second tour
oui aucun d'entre eux net au second tour
dans ces législatives partielles et
pourtant c'était autrefois des fiefs en
marche où il y avait des scores bien
plus haut alors certes la participation
était très faible ça pose la question
bien sûr de ces élections qui mobilise
très peu mais ça en dit long sur le
désamour de ce parti sur finalement la
dynamique qui était celle qui avait
permis à tous ces députés et un de
mettre leurs visages à côté de celui des
marines des mâles macro et d'être élues
immédiatement à l'assemblée nationale
sans avoir auparavant fait de politiques
pour certains d'entre eux eh bien cette
fois ci c'est fini la mécanique en
marche est à l'arrêt alors du coup
alexis c'est la crise à la république en
marche
oui c'est la crise christophe castaner
qui remplace gilles legendre pour
prendre la tête du groupe à l'assemblée
nationale se retrouve sur un tas de
cendres du moins une maison bien mal en
point
certains sont déjà partis s'étaient
sacha houllier pour
monter un parti monsieur person qui
quitte ses fonctions aurore bergé qui
quitte ses fonctions dans le groupe
riposte
on voit bien que il y à là tous les
déçus finalement de la république en
marche or verger qui disait avoir tout
donné pour ce mouvement et qui
finalement ne récupère que très peu de
choses les ambitieux s'en vont montrent
leurs cours en parallèle ou bien
rejoignent le modem parce qu'ils ont
compris que cette étiquette là serait
négative dans les échéances à venir
un parti qui a du mal à s'ancrer dans le
territoire et les prochaines élections
sénatoriales régional et bien ça va être
beaucoup plus compliqué encore pour en
marge de fer est bien une
une construction réelle donc l'idée est
de partir un peu à droite à gauche au
modem ou ailleurs et finalement c'est
une stratégie qui peut être payante
parce que en marche ne s'arrête pas mais
ça devient une diaspora ou finalement
tous les députés anciennement marcheurs
vont trouver une nouvelle étiquette et
continuer d'être fidèle à emmanuel
macron pour préparer 2022
mais dans d'autres écuries alors
finalement est-ce que c'est grave pour
emmanuel macron est-ce qu'il ya besoin
d'un parti pour se faire réélire ce que
finalement l'international
c'est pas une chance pour lui oui
clairement
déjà en 2010 est emmanuel macron n'a pas
eu besoin d'un parti pour se faire élire
c'était une coquille vide qui lui
permettait de dire qu'il avait un
mouvement de fédérer d'avoir là à
l'époque des gens qui croyaient qu'ils
étaient ces marcheurs du bas qui
pensaient à que la transversalité était
une réalité pour faire du porte à porte
pour changer le monde d'une certaine
façon
tout ça s'est vite évaporé une fois
quesnel macron a été élu surtout grâce
bien à son réseau qu'il avait pu faire
dans la banque d'affaires
dans les cercles d'affaires français la
finance internationale les français
aussi à l'étranger
donc il n'a pas besoin d'un parti et il
le sait aujourd'hui il parle même de
faire une maison commune une coalition
avec le modem et d'autres et même si en
marche et minoritaires mais ce n'est pas
grave parce que ce parti là finalement
il a vécu ça suffisait c'était
uniquement pour être élu et c'est très
grave parce que aujourd'hui on a un
homme en france qui concentre à peu près
tous les pouvoirs emmanuel macron
président isolé à à l'elysée simplement
il est enfermé dans ce palais avec des
cordes de crs autour de lui et il décide
absolument de tout avec un gouvernement
qui là aussi est aux ordres
regardez comme gérald darmanin essaye de
mettre aux ordres
la presse avec cette nouvelle doctrine
pour empêcher les journalistes de faire
le travail lors des manifestations
regardez monsieur dupont moretti garde
des sceaux attaqué par deux syndicats de
magistrats aujourd'hui parce que trop de
conflits d'intérêts avec ce monsieur et
les procès qui arrive de nicolas sarkozy
regardez la façon dont la police a été
utilisé aussi pour bien asseoir un ordre
républicain pour certains mais parfois
un ordre bien violent lors des
manifestations des gilet jaune tout ça
ne va pas et c'est très grave
et aujourd'hui emmanuel macron bien
qu'est ce qu'il fait et bien il ne lui
reste plus que son image donc il se
réinvente encore une fois changements de
costumes changement de ton changement de
braquet le ni droite ni gauche a vécu ça
c'était pour 2017
aujourd'hui il devient le président
français qui agit un peu partout dans le
monde discours à l'onu la libye le liban
un peu partout il est là pour résoudre
les problèmes ou en créer de nouveaux
mais aujourd'hui on ne peut pas attendre
2022 et croire que la vème république
est un régime démocratique
c'est grave et la démocratie ce n'est
pas ça merci beaucoup alexis poulain
pour votre et vito je rappelle que vous
êtes éditorialistes le royaume uni
adopte de nouvelles mesures pour lutter
contre le coc vie de 19 avec plus de 40
mille morts et une courbe des
contaminations inquiétante dans le pays
londres serre la vis le premier ministre
boris johnson a annoncé en personne ce
mardi les précisions de louis xiv
face à la tempête corona le royaume uni
change de cap
une deuxième vague menace le pays alors
l'exécutif annonce la mise en place de
nouvelles restrictions qui entreront en
vigueur ce jeudi en angleterre à partir
de jeudi tous les pubs bars et
restaurants doivent se limiter au
service à table sauf pour les produits à
emporter
à l'instar de tous les lieux qui
accueillent du public
ils doivent fermer à 22h et pour aider
la police à faire respecter cette règle
je crains que cela signifie hélas une
fermeture réel à 22h et pas seulement la
prise des dernières commandes car la
simplicité est d'une importance capitale
dans les autres régions de grande
bretagne les autorités locales prennent
leurs propres décisions dans la lutte
face à l'épidémie
des mesures similaires sont par exemple
attendue en écosse
nous allons instaurer un couvre-feu
national strictes à partir de vendredi
les pubs bars et restaurants devront
fermer à 22h
ces fermetures nocturnes une mauvaise
nouvelle pour les restaurants et les
bars déjà très en difficulté depuis le
confinement décrété le 23 mars dernier
nous sommes très déçus en tant que
secteur les pubs ont travaillé
incroyablement dur depuis leur
réouverture
et ils sont déjà confrontés à des
moments très très difficiles avec ces
restrictions en place plus de 90% des
pubs maintenant rouvert mais moins de la
moitié sont actuellement rentable
les restrictions annoncées ce mardi en
particulier l'absence de négociation
d'un horaire de fermeture vont donc
porté un coup dur à nombre d'entre eux
de nouvelles mesures alors qu'au royaume
uni
la situation sanitaire se dégrade de
manière inquiétante pour la première
fois depuis le mois de juin les
responsables des services médicaux ont
relevé ce lundi le niveau d'alerté à 4
ce qui correspond à un niveau de
contamination élevé
afin d'inverser la tendance le
gouvernement de boris johnson n'a pas
hésité à annoncer la mise en place de
lourdes sanctions jusqu'à onze mille
euros damende pour une personne testée
positive au corona virus qui ne
respecteraient pas les consignes
d'isolement de son côté le conseil
scientifique du gouvernement assure que
le pays voit ces contaminations doubler
tous les sept jours
d'après ce dernier si la situation
n'évolue pas dans le bon sens elle
pourrait entraîner plus de 200 morts par
jour dès le milieu du mois de novembre à
la situation au liban à présent on parle
d'une situation dramatique
catastrophique lincendie du port de
beyrouth a précipité un pays déjà
fragile au bord du gouffre et un nouveau
gouvernement de mission doit être encore
être formé pour l'instant il n'y a aucun
consensus autour du dossier
c'est inquiétant pour le président
michel aoun de plus en plus cible des
critiques de ses compatriotes florian
lambert
l'enfer c'est en ce terme que le
président michel aoun qualifie la
situation libanaise actuelle si un
nouveau gouvernement ne se forme pas
dans les plus brefs délais nous n'avons
plus le luxe du temps
vous avez dit que vous aviez proposé
beaucoup de choses mais n'ont pas été
approuvées si cette information du
gouvernement n'ait pas approuvé
où allons-nous en enfer bien sûr le
liban ne supporte pas les coups d'état
ou les chocs
il a été construit sur la démocratie et
sur l'équilibré entre les composantes de
la société
c'est notre fondement une semaine après
la date butoir fixée par emmanuel macron
les querelles partisanes autour du
portefeuille des finances entravent la
formation du nouveau gouvernement dirigé
par mustapha hadid six rendez-vous de
fin octobre
ce sur quoi vos dirigeants se sont
engagés n'est pas au rendez vous nous
devons en tirer les conséquences alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
soit rien n'a été fait à ce moment là
c'est clair je devrais dire à la
communauté internationale nous ne
pouvons pas être au rendez-vous de
l'aide au liban mais je devrai aussi
vous expliquer expliquer aux libanaises
et aux libanais nous étions prêts à vous
aider vos dirigeants en ont décidé
autrement
le liban vit depuis un an l'une des
pires crises économiques sociales et
politiques de son histoire une crise
amplifié par la pandémie de kobe 19 et
l'explosion tragique le 4 août au port
de beyrouth qui a fait des centaines de
victimes et des dizaines de milliers de
sans abri
la communauté internationale dont la
france exige du liban des réformes
structurelles en contrepartie d'un
soutien international de plusieurs
milliards d'euros et dans quelques
instants nous parlons de l'assemblée
générale de l'onu qui se tient
actuellement à new york marquée par des
allocutions de chefs d'états distance le
président américain donald trump se
montre très critique à l'égard de la
chine puis nous parlerons des manuels
macro et de redjeb tayyip erdogan
ils ont évoqué par téléphone la
situation en méditerranée orientale
rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
la france n'est pas le seul pays qui a
eu des colonies dans le monde mais c'est
le seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter un partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune des colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nos africains de porter à la
tête de nos états des gens qui sont
animés par la recherche de l'intérêt de
leur population
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort ici on reçoit c'est
qu'on ne voit pas ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est un père dit
d'interdire
[Musique]
est ce que vous croyez qu'avec cette
candidature du pdc y votre parti reste
crédible
à partir du moment où le plaisant et
colombier revient de course
nous allons remettre la côte d'ivoire
sur les rails de la démocratie et
retrouver la cohésion sociale que nous
avons perdu malheureusement on peut
réellement parler de climat
insurrectionnel en côte d'ivoire si on
permettait aux ivoiriens de manifester
librement d'exprimer leurs opinions en
toute liberté
il n'y aurait pas de direction nous
allons retrouver le pouvoir planier
cette élection et il n'y aura pas de
chasse aux sorcières que les partisans
du rhdp se rassurent nous n'avons pas
les poursuivre pour des fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation près des warnings
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et d'un fonds talents de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté qatar ce trop fine il
ya un tournant et on refermait à vivre
mais dans une autre direction c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais plaint d'une décision à
vraisemblable pour vous ça dépend quelle
valeur on attribuait la mort la vie
humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
morales un débat éthique
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
14 juillet 2015 et signe à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président avait décidé de rompre
l'accord et d'imposer son régime de
sanctions au niveau international sur
1000 iran en grave difficulté au plan
économique et social pour la chine c'est
une très belle opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avaient ils un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en bougeant par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui va en profiter pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de pau au moyen orient
[Musique]
entre 800 et 1000 tonnes de fuel se sont
déversés dans les eaux turquoises
mauricienne ce qu'il faudrait étendre
l'enquète aux autorités portuaires voir
plus haut
nous devrons annoncé une enquête une
fois maintenant établir la chaîne de
responsabilités nationales
il faut savoir que la partie arrière du
bateau contient encore environ 50 à 100
tonnes de fioul
donc ça pourrait aussi actuellement se
fracasser et causé un deuxième
déversement de pétrole plus ça arrive
après les communes 19 avons secteur
hôtelier et touristique est à genoux
l'ensemble des impacts de la catastrophe
sur l'environnement marin mais aussi sur
les populations niveau de la santé vont
se faire ressentir pendant des décennies
il faut s'attendre aujourd'hui à maurice
aussi un désastre sanitaire
il est catastrophe on a vécu voilà
pourquoi je suis pas si pessimiste que
c'est
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
pensez vous que malgré les apparences la
france joue un rôle dans l'élection à
venir en côte d'ivoire la france
c'est ainsi que de polichinelle je ne
crois pas qu'il appartient à la france
dé régler des problèmes internes voir le
bénin ouattara et son régime son antre
débris mais le peuple il faut demander
au régime ivoiris de faire en sorte d
n'est pas crisper davantage les
positions la tension est déjà trop lourd
ou demander un report du scrutin prévu
le 31 octobre
organiser les élections en côte d'ivoire
dans les circonstances pareilles c'est
le conduit la côte d'ivoire dans un menu
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi 22 septembre 2001 trump
erdogan à xi jingping poutine rouhani
macron les 193 chefs d etat membre de
l'onu entendu au premier jour de leur
assemblée générale
elle est prise de parole par
visioconférence crise du coronavirus
oblige
antonio guterres est chef de
l'organisation a appelé à éviter une
nouvelle guerre froide
le président américain s'en est pris à
la chine pour lui elle doit être tenu
pour responsable de la pandémie
el assine rétorque et accuse trump de
propager un virus politique qu'à l'ol
[Musique]
vers une reprise du dialogue selon le
palais de l'élysée emmanuel macron et le
président turc recep tayyip erdogan
s'entretiennent ce soir par téléphone
est les tensions en méditerranée
orientale seront l'un des principaux
sujets de conversation en quarts à
d'ailleurs annoncé ce mardi que la
turquie et la grèce sont prêtes à
entamer des pourparlers aie les deux
pays se disputent des zones
potentiellement riches en gaz naturel
[Musique]
face au co vide le dispositif sanitaire
est allégé depuis aujourd'hui dans les
écoles maternelles et élémentaires de
france la détection d'un élève positif
au coronavirus n'entraînera plus
automatiquement la fermeture de sa
classe seuls sept élèves sera mis en
quarantaine durant sept jours un
assouplissement et plusieurs objectifs
éviter les fermetures inutile gardait le
plus possible de classe et d'école
ouverte alors faut-il les maintenir
ouvertes coûte que coûte en dépit du
regain de l'épidémie
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
nouveau rebondissement dans la sphère
geneviève legay cette militante de 73
ans blessé en mars 2019 à nice lors
d'une intervention policière
selon mediapart à l'igpn aurait conclu à
une disproportion de cette charge
survenus pendant une manifestation des
gilets jaunes
à l'époque le président de la république
lui-même avait défendu une version
policière aujourd'hui démentent
[Musique]
l'onu célèbre cette année ses 75 ans
dans un contexte particulier en raison
de la pandémie de covin 19 peu de
diplomates donc dans le vaste complexe
des nations unies à new york est les
discours ont été prononcés par les 193
chefs d'états membres par
visioconférence souvent enregistrés et
parmi les prises de paroles marquantes
cet après midi celle du président
américain
et il a été très offensif vis-à-vis de
la chine lors de sa brève allocution de
six minutes alors que nous oeuvrons pour
réaliser cet avenir radieux nous devons
exiger de la nation qui est à l'origine
de ce fléau mondial qu'elle rende des
comptes je veux parler de la chine
lorsque le virus est apparu la chine a
interdit les voyages à l'intérieur du
pays tout en permettant que des vols
quittent la chine bien fait le monde
la chine a condamné l'interdiction de
voyager que j'ai imposé à son pays alors
même que annulé leurs vols intérieurs et
enfermer leurs citoyens chez eux
le gouvernement chinois et
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
est pour ainsi dire contrôlé par la
chine ont prétendu à tort qu'il
n'existait aucune preuve de transmission
entre nos mains plus tard ils ont
prétendu à tort que les personnes
asymptomatiques n'était pas contagieuse
les nations unies doivent tenir la chine
comptable de ses actes nous nous sommes
retirés de l'accord désastreux sur le
nucléaire iranien et avons imposé de
très lourdes sanctions au premier état
au monde à soutenir le terrorisme
nous avons réduit à néant le califat de
l'oeil elle à 100%
nous avons tué son fondateur et
dirigeant al baghdadi et nous avons
éliminé le pire terroriste au monde
qasem soleimani et si la china aurait
porté par la suite est accusée trump de
propager un virus politiques à l'onu le
président chinois xi jinping a préféré
axer son discours sur la solidarité
mondiale face à la pandémie
face au virus nous devons renforcer la
solidarité et surmonter ensemble cette
épreuve nous devons respecter la science
faire valoir pleinement le rôle de
leader de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé et apporter une réponse collective
internationale pour gagner résolument
cette guerre sale in sanitaire à
l'échelle mondiale toute pratique de
politisation et de stigmatisation doit
être rejetée face au virus
nous devons adopter des mesures de
contrôle intégré et régulière nous
devons chaque couche et promouvoir de
manière ordonnée la relance de
l'économie et la réouverture des écoles
pour créer de l'emploi relancer
l'économie et rétablir l'ordre et le
dynamisme économique et sociaux des plus
en fin d'après midi le président russe a
notamment souligné la nécessité pour les
cinq membres permanents de l'onu de se
réunir dans un contexte de fragmentation
entre les pays
notre correspondant antoine claireaux
nous donne plus de précisions
pour commencer vladimir poutine a
rappelé l'importance de l'organisation
des nations unies et sa charte pierre
angulaire des relations internationales
un texte qui garantit la souveraineté
des états et l'égalité entre ces mêmes
états il a loué le rôle du conseil de
sécurité un organisme qui je cite
fonctionne et qui a permis d'éviter
plusieurs conflits dans un second temps
il a longuement évoqué la crise du coc
u19 une crise sanitaire mais aussi socio
économiques qui il a dit prendra du
temps à se résorber
pour tenter d'y remédier le président
russe a fait une proposition la création
d'un espace eurasiatique libre de
sanctions ou les biens de première
nécessité pourraient circuler librement
je porte votre attention sur la
procession proposition russe de création
des couloirs verts qui ne connaissent
pas des barrières pour acheminer des
médicaments des vivres des moyens de
protection qui sont nécessaires pour la
lutte contre la pandémie en général
c'était épuration du commerce
international
les barrières des sanctions illégitime
tout cela pourrait être une bonne base
pour le rétablissement est qu économique
pour la lutte contre le chômage
vladimir poutine ensuite souligné la
nécessité de mettre tout le potentiel de
l'industrie pharmaceutique mondiale au
service du développement et de la mise
sur le marché de vaccins il a fait
savoir que la russie qui dispose de son
propre vaccin le spoutnik v est prête à
coopérer avec les pays qui en feront la
demande
enfin le président russe a rappelé la
volonté de la russie de parvenir à une
stabilité stratégique entre les pays
d'où l'importance des traités de
limitation des armements
la priorité c'est la poursuite de
l'accord entre la russie et les etats
unis sur les armes aux offensives qui
expirent en 2021 et nous menons des
discussions avec nos partenaires
américains et nous insistons sur la
nécessité de limiter la portée des
missiles concernés et dé l'année
dernière j'insiste là dessus nous avons
proposé un moratoire sur l'installation
de tels missiles en europe et dans
d'autres zones
tant que les états unis ne serons pas
signataires d'hôtel et pour l'instant
nous n'entendons pas de réponse de la
part des états unis à notre proposition
le discours de vladimir poutine se
voulait rassembleur une intervention
lors de laquelle il a souligné
l'importance des grandes institutions
internationales avec en premier lieu les
nations unies et plus particulièrement
le conseil de sécurité le président
français emmanuel macron s'est lui
exprimé en début de soirée pendant plus
de 40 minutes pour plus de précisions
nous retrouvons
mona a boudé lors emmanuel macron s'est
exprimé à l'occasion de la soixante
quinzième assemblée générale un long
discours axé sur la pandémie et les
relations internationales selon le
président de la république il faut
apprendre à vivre avec ce virus et tous
les efforts seront déployés pour le
vaincre écoutez le d'abord je crois en
la science et la connaissance et
l'humanité vaincre à cette pandémie un
remède sera trouvé mais dans cette
attente dont nul ne sait combien elles
durent à chacun de nos pays n'aura
d'autre choix que d'apprendre à vivre
avec le virus et le monde devra
apprendre à vivre avec cette nouvelle
réalité qui s'impose à tous révèlent nos
vulnérabilités nous place devant nos
immédiate responsabilités je vous le
disais plusieurs sujets ont été abordés
le discours a été axée sur les relations
internationales il a mentionné la
situation en libye au liban en afrique
ou encore la relation entre la chine et
les états unis il indiqué que le monde
ne devait pas tourné autour du conflit
de ces deux pays écoutez le il faudra
compter à l'avenir avec ces nouveaux
équilibres qui sont en train de se
définir
il faudra compter sur la force des
bonnes volontés parce que le monde tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui ne peut pas se
résumer à la rivalité entre la chine et
les états unis quel que soit le poids
mondial de ces deux grandes puissances
quel que soit aussi l'histoire qui nous
lie en particulier aux états unis
d'amérique les fragilités que je viens
d'évoquer nous impose de rebâtir un
nouvel ordre et impose à l'europe de
prendre toute sa part de responsabilité
c'est à dire de porter ses valeurs son
goût de l'avenir et de savoir bâtir des
solutions nouvelles
après la chine et les etats-unis manuel
macron a parlé de l'union européenne
notamment il a indiqué qu'il fallait
rétablir un nouvel ordre grâce à la
cohésion de tous ces pays des 27 pays
membres de l'union européenne plusieurs
thématiques ont été abordées je vous
disait de l'afrique au moyen-orient il
s'est notamment adressé au liban afin
qu'un gouvernement se forme le plus
rapidement possible le président de la
république a également félicité la
normalisation des relations entre israël
et deux pays arabes le parrainer les
épées les émirats arabes unis mais il a
également eu un mot pour la palestine
écoutez le la paix au proche orient
reste une nécessité
d'abord pour les israéliens et les
palestiniens mais pour nous tous je me
réjouis qu'il sera elles obtiennent la
reconnaissance de nouveaux pays arabes
c'est une reconnaissance légitime c'est
aussi un gage d'espoir pour l'avenir
pour autant une paix juste et durable
nécessite avant tout de retrouver les
voies et moyens d'une négociation
décisive qui permette aux palestiniens
de disposer enfin de leurs droits je ne
crois pas à une paix qui se construira
sur l'hégémonie ou l'humiliation
quand bien même celles-ci seraient
compensés par de l'argent car nous
savons trop qu'on ne compense pas
l'humiliation d'un peuple par de
l'argent par ailleurs le président a de
la république qui a eu un mot pour la
russie il demande que la lumière soit
faite concernant je cite la tentative
d'assassinât contre un opposant
politique comprenez alexeï navalni et
voilà pour les quelques sujets abordés
lors de ce long discours en discours il
faut le savoir
axé sur les relations internationales le
multilatéralisme surtout l'importance de
la coopération et on lisait donald trump
critiques envers la chine mais aussi
l'iran envers l'onu également retour en
images sur quatre années électrique
entre le président américain et les
nations unies avec walid bennani dès son
accession à la maison blanche le
désormais président entre up applique
ses préceptes résumer en un slogan
l'amérique d'abord il ne tarde pas à
tancer les nations unies sur leur
prétendue inutilité l'onu un potentiel
tellement énorme
elle n'est pas à la hauteur de son
potentiel quand est ce que vous avez vu
nations unies résoudre des problèmes
elles ne le font pas elles en créent
rapidement et dénonce l'accord de paris
sur le climat qui l'avait accusé pendant
la campagne je cite de tuer l'emploi et
le commerce
votre exemple du multilatéralisme
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien et
vigoureusement critiquée par le
président américain pour son premier
discours aux nations unies donald trump
expose sa défiance vis-à-vis de
l'organisation
ils menacent de réduire la contribution
des états unis qui sont alors les plus
gros contributeur financier de
l'institution
irrité par les critiques de l'unesco
concernant les colonies israéliennes
le milliardaire américain annonce que le
pays ne sera plus un pays membres de
l'agencé onusienne
autre départ majeur celui de l'accord de
paris sur le climat en 2018 alors que
les critiques onusienne pleuvent sur sa
gestion des migrants il réaffirme sa
posture isolationnistes et dénonce les
dogmes de l'institution donald trump ne
digère pas également les propos du
conseil des droits de l'homme à l'égard
de sa politique intérieure
votre départ et non des moindres le
retrait unilatéral de l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien
au grand dam de ses alliés à un an des
élections présidentielles américaines
donald trump réaffirme son credo il
dénonce pêle-mêle la chine l'iran ou
encore les organisations humanitaires
en cette année de pandémie la maison
blanche échaudés par l'attitude de l'om
est vis-à-vis de la chine se retire
unilatéralement de l' agence de santé
internationales par ailleurs deux
membres de la cour pénale internationale
sont placés sur liste noire américaine
en raison des investigations de
l'institution judiciaire sur des
citoyens américains
enfin le président étasunien déciderait
appliquer les sanctions onusiennes
envers l'iran une annonce symbolique
puisque les états unis sont plus aidé à
partie de l'accord
depuis leur retrait de 2018 et pour
parler de la posture des prises de
position des états unis au sein de l'onu
nous sommes en direct depuis washington
avec olivier py ton avocat au barreau de
washington c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur
[Musique]
olivier python merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors le
discours de trump à l'onu
beaucoup disent qu'il ressemblait à un
discours de campagne présidentielle
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est clairement un discours de campagne
présidentielle on est à moins de 45
jours maintenant de l'élection donc
évidemment rôle alors olivier python on
a quelques soucis techniques
malheureusement la liaison est mauvaise
on va quand même réessayer olivier py
ton de vous avoir nous parlions donc à
l'instant du discours de donald trump a
loué nu il ressemblait donc un discours
de campagne présidentielle c'est ce que
vous nous disiez à l'instant est-ce
qu'on a retrouvé la lésion olivier
python mais au delà des soucis
techniques donc olivier python qui était
en direct avec nous depuis washington
et on va passer à la crise sanitaire qui
a mis en lumière parfois le manque de
solidarité entre les pays membres de
l'onu
pour le moment aucun consensus n'a été
trouvé pour aider à freiner l'épidémie
le coronavirus n'a manifestement pas
aidé à mettre de côté les désaccords ali
la faa mouzon cette année fait rarissime
les 193 pays membres de l'organisation
ont tenu à participer à l'événement six
jours pendant lesquels tous les états
membres auront l'occasion de s'exprimer
la pandémie de kobe 19 sera bien entendu
au coeur des discussions
le secrétaire général antonio guterres
elle souhaite renouveler ses voeux pour
la mise au point d'un vaccin contre la
copie de 19 et la distribution équitable
de celui ci dans le monde
un appel qui risque fort de n'être qu'un
voeu pieux
encore la semaine dernière on apprenait
qu'un petit groupe de pays riches
s'étaient déjà réservé plus de la moitié
des futurs doses de vaccin l'épidémie
faut le dire a révélé l'absence de
solidarité entre les états membres
en près de huit mois seul un recueil de
résolution à la pandémie a été adoptée
par l'assemblée générale sans pour
autant arriver à un consensus
les états unis et israël s'ils sont tout
simplement opposé pour ce qui est de
l'action concrète un appel de fonds de
10 3 milliards de dollars a été lancé
pour aider les pays les plus vulnérables
à ce jour il n'a recueilli qu'un quart
du financement nécessaire sur le plan
géopolitique l'agent daris que d'être
très chargée avec un dossier brûlant le
dossier iranien alors que washington
vient de décider unilatéralement de
rétablir les sanctions de l'onu à
l'encontre de téhéran
quasiment les seuls dans le monde entier
a estimé que ces sanctions sont en
vigueur les états unis menace
explicitement tous les autres pays de
sanctions si ces derniers ne se pliait
pas à leur décision et si des états
membres de l'onu ne remplissent pas
leurs obligations pour appliquer ces
sanctions les etats-unis sont prêts à
utiliser leurs propres outils pour punir
ces défaillances dans ce contexte le
discours de donald trump mardi à
l'assemblée générale de l'onu est
particulièrement attendu côté russe
vladimir poutine s'exprimera également
ce mardi et devront être évoqué la
situation en biélorussie à propos de
laquelle russes et américains seront
voix des accusations d'ingérence
sans oublier la situation au proche
orient ou encore les tensions en côte
d'ivoire à l' approche des élections
présidentielles cette 75e session
s'ouvre donc avec un enjeu de taille
pour l'organisation internationale
l'avenir du multilatéralisme et le
maintien des équilibres mondiaux dont la
crise sanitaire a mis à nu la fragilité
et on s'arrête maintenant sur cette
conversation téléphonique peut être
décisive selon le palais de l'élysée
manuel maquereau et le président turc
recep tayyip erdogan vont s'entretenir
ce soir par téléphone les tensions en
méditerranée orientale seront l'un des
principaux sujets de conversation ankara
a annoncé d'ailleurs ce mardi que la
turquie et la grèce sont prêtes à
entamer des pourparlers les deux pays se
disputent des zones potentiellement
riche en
gaz naturel je vous propose d'écouter le
président turc dr samy messaoud
notre priorité est de résoudre les
conflits par un dialogue sincère fondées
sur le droit international et une base
équitable
cependant je veux clairement affirmé que
nous n'allons jamais tolérer aucune
imposition harcèlement ou attaque dans
le sens contraire ça m'a amusé a dans ce
but nous aimerions proposer la tenue
d'une conférence régionale incluant les
chypriotes turcs lors de laquelle les
droits et des intérêts de tous les pays
de la région seraient considérés diane
lane mentionné techniques fédéraux et
pour en parler nous sommes avec mériadec
raffray journaliste spécialiste des
questions de défense mériadec raffray
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors ankara qui annonce
donc que la turquie et la grèce étaient
prêtes à entamer des pourparlers sur
leur différend et puis cet appel
téléphonique entre ritchey tayyip
erdogan
emmanuel macron est ce qu'on peut parler
on peut penser à un début de détente
écoutez il est trop tôt pour le dire il
va falloir qu'on voit les effets
concrets sur le terrain entre guillemets
de ce coup de fil écoutez c'est toujours
bien de se parler est effectivement ces
dernières semaines ces derniers mois la
tension entre les deux hommes était
monté presque aux extrêmes je rappelle
par exemple il ya quelques jours
erdogan fait quelques semaines erdogan
d'isère encore à propos de macron un
ambitieux incapable bon et même macron
n'a pas été sur ce registre là en
revanche cette tension entre les deux
hommes elle était également palpable en
méditerranée en particulier en
méditerranée orientale où actuellement
une quarantaine à une cinquantaine de
navires de guerre sont présents on est
un peu revenu au temps de la guerre
froide des navires turcs en nombre
important et des navires français aussi
et je vous rappelle que mi juin il ya eu
un incident inédit entre 2
gat une française et une est une turque
donc la tension était évidemment à la
fois palpable au niveau diplomatique
elle était aussi un des potentiels
en tout cas au niveau militaire donc il
va falloir voir concrètement comment on
fait
le comédien je les fruits de ce dialogue
va se concrétiser
et pour terminer je rappelle enfin que
les contentieux sont importants
aujourd'hui entre la turquie et la
france et de d'ordre très différents
alors vous rappeliez les tensions très
vives entre emmanuel macron est chez
hyper douanes ces dernières semaines l
initiative de cet appel vient du
président français une initiative
acceptée par le président du rck est ce
que c'est un bon signe tout de même
oui bien sûr certains disaient de
l'entourage du président français qu'il
était pardonnez moi l'expression
remonté comme un coucou contraire dogan
jeu mais c'est entre guillemets je veux
dire qu'il était il faisait il ne
cachait pas en fait son agacement
vis-à-vis devises à bidart ganet delà de
l'attitude
enfin évidemment de ses déclarations
mais également de les faits et gestes de
la turquie dans une zone d'influencé que
se partagent les turcs aujourd'hui et la
france je veux bien sûr parler de la
méditerranée donc voilà donc les les
militaires disent est du côté français
que les canaux de discussions de
dialogue habituel et est ouvert que les
chaînes de commandement et les chaînes
de commandement national était robuste
mais évidemment dans cette situation un
peu comme du temps de la guerre froide
où les bâtiments de guerre se côtoient
vous savez pour un bâtiment guerre en
fait l'espace se réduit considérablement
donc dans cet espace un peu réduit
aujourd'hui plusieurs de nombreux
bâtiments de guerre se côtoient un
incident est toujours probable
et dans ce cadre là comment dirais-je
une erreur humaine d'appréciation peut
conduire à mettre une
13 sur un brasier en fait qui ne demande
qu'à éclater voyait donc de ce point de
vue là évidemment la diplomatie retrouve
ses droits ça me parlait de bonne augure
alors pourquoi comment est ce qu'on peut
comprendre que le climat temps à
s'apaiser
maintenant qu'est-ce qui a changé
précisément écoutez je vais avoir en
tout état de cause ce qui est clair
c'est que la france a envoyé un ou deux
signaux forts apportant notamment par
exemple en mettant sur le la table de
l'otan l'incident qui a eu lieu en jean
à mi-chemin mi juin dernier entre les
deux bâtiments de guerre français et
turcs
les autorités françaises disent qu'elles
ont envoyé un signal aux autorités
turques que celui-ci distel a priori a
été reçu cinq sur cinq
on peut également évoquer le l'annnonce
du contrat de rafale vendus donc par la
france en tout cas sur le point d'être
vendus par la france à la lamal à
l'armée grecque s'est également aussi un
signal un symbole de force et talent
cela donnerait à la grèce un potentiel
militaire qu'elle n'a pas aujourd'hui là
bien sûr des avions mirage français mais
qui n'ont pas la capacité et la qui ne
sont pas si moderne que les rafales
donc voilà au moins deux signaux forts
envers erdogan
ceci dit il faut pour équilibrer les
choses il faut rappeler que erdogan
n'est pas quelqu'un que l'on pût eux que
l'on peut intimider facilement c'est
quelqu'un qui comprend la force il
déploie une stratégie pragmatique qui
est la sienne qu'on peut critiquer ou
pas c'est une stratégie impériale
nationaliste qui est historique des
bases historiques qui se déploient
notamment vers l'ouest et et vers le sud
c'est une strate stratégiques ont
qualifié de néo ottomane c'est quelqu'un
qui comprend
la loi de la force comme dans les
relations internationales
il a eu un contentieux vif contentieux
avec les américains il a un vif
contentieux avec les russes de puissance
par ailleurs avec laquelle le erdogan
travail discutent et négocie donc voilà
donc en fait taire dogan comprend la
force et les spécialistes qualifiés
la réaction de la france suite à ses
dernières incidents en méditerranée de
symbolique c'est à dire que la france
n'a pas été très comment dire lg2 très
agressive dans la réaction
dans sa réaction face à l'agressivité
pour le coup de la turquie merci
beaucoup mériadec raffray d'avoir
partagé votre analyse je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste spécialiste de
défense est resté avec nous sur rt
france dans quelques instants retour sur
l'allégement du protocole sanitaire dans
les écoles mises en oeuvre aujourd'hui
et puis nous parlerons de la charge de
police qui avait blessé
la gilet jaune geneviève le guen c'était
le 23 mars 2019 et bien l'igpn pointe la
responsabilité du commissaire à la tête
des opérations
restez avec nous a tout de suite sur rt
france
que vous croyez qu'avec cette
candidature du pdc y votre parti reste
crédible partir du moment où le
président henri konan bédié redire la
course
nous allons remettre la côte d'ivoire
sur les rails de la démocratie et
retrouver la cohésion sociale que nous
avons perdu malheureusement on peu près
également parler de climat
insurrectionnel en côte d'ivoire si on
permettait aux ivoiriens de manifester
est libre d'exprimer leurs opinions en
toute liberté
il n'y aurait pas de piment nous allons
retrouver le pouvoir gagner ces
élections et il n'y aura pas de chasse
aux sorcières que les partisans du rhdp
se rassurent nous n'avons pas les
poursuivre pour les fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation près d ivoire
[Musique]
quelle reprise économique pour l'après
qu'ovide 19 à quoi peut-on s'attendre on
a été dans l'oeil du cyclone cet été en
fait ça fait à peu près trente ans que
la croissance structurelle en france
baisse tôt qu'elle va continuer à être
au mieux médiocre et au pire
catastrophique les prévisions que
peuvent faire le fmi ou la deutsche bank
c'est des prévisions au doigt mouillé ça
n'a pas grande valeur si l'état était
capable de relancer l'économie
la france elle prit plus développés du
monde beaucoup de pays était déjà en
récession donc le coc vide n'a été qu'un
catalyseur en fait de ce qui s'est passé
qu'une demi croise il faut que ceux qui
prennent des risques gagne plus d'argent
que ce qui entraîne pas parler de
croissance comprend toutes les mesures
qu'il faut pour que les entrepreneurs ne
gagne pas d'argent
j'ai un peu pas bien sérieux
[Musique]
et
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 21h30 heure
française
elle la situation sanitaire en france
tout de suite et les derniers chiffres
de santé publique france l'agent
s'annonce plus de dix mille nouvelles
contaminations aux collines 19 ans 24
heures 68 personnes décédées à l'hôpital
et 651 patients sont en réanimation et
le taux de positivité à lui progressé à
6,1 pour cent contre 5,9 pour cent la
veille
et dans ce contexte depuis ce matin le
protocole sanitaire est allégé dans les
écoles maternelles et primaires
nouveauté si un enfant est diagnostiquée
positive au coronavirus le reste de sa
classe ne sera plus considéré comme cas
contacts et restera donc ouverte des
nouvelles règles qui s'appuie sur un
avis du haut conseil pour la santé
publique selon lequel je cite et les
enfants sont peu à risque de formes
graves et peu actif dans la transmission
du co lead 19 alors comment réagissent
les parents d'élèves
éléments de réponse tout de suite avec
piotr taja tu sais il est allé à la
rencontre ce matin à paris de parents
d'élèves
c'est très difficile de se prononcer
parce qu'on n'a pas forcément les
informations n'est pas virologues
épidémiologistes
donc on se fie au protocole qui sont
annoncés aux mesures qui sont prises
maintenant c'est vrai que si moi
personnellement il ya un cas kovy dans
la classe je retirerais mon enfant par
mesure de précaution quoi mais je pense
que c'est une bonne chose car en fait le
guet en france qui avait actuellement
était un petit peu lourd est là comme on
a été vérifié que les enfants étaient
assez peu porteur du virus
donc je pense que
c'est une bonne chose et que ça va
permettre une plus grande fluidité dans
les cours et dans la circulation du
collège moi ce qui me pose surtout
question c'est qu'il faudrait que par
exemple à paris que l'éducation
nationale se met d'accord avec la mairie
de paris parce qu'en fait les protocoles
éducation nationale ne sont pas les
mêmes que ceux mairie de paris cf dans
une même école
il ya des enfants qui vont jouer tous
ensemble d'une manière brasser pendant
la cour de récré parce que là pendant la
récré du matin ou l'après midi parce que
c'est sous la responsabilité de ducasse
nationale mais que sur les temps
périscolaires et les temps de cantine
comme si les consignes mairie de paris
il faut qu'il reste par classe et qui se
mélangent pas alors je trouve que déjà
par exemple dans une ville comme paris
pourrait que la ville et l'état se
mettent d'accord avant
avant d'alléger un quelconque protocole
sanitaire en fait finalement pour moi
c'est pas la question
enfin ce qu'on vit d'un dispositif
sanitaire allégé donc depuis aujourd'hui
dans les écoles maternelles et
élémentaires de france avec plusieurs
objectifs éviter les fermetures inutile
garder le plus possible de classe et
d'école ouverte alors faut-il maintenir
ouvertes coûte que coûte ces écoles en
dépit du regain de l'épidémie
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir et pour en débattre nous sommes
avec kevin bosse fait professeur
d'histoire bonsoir à vos côtés alain tu
as le professeur également écho
secrétaire snuipp fsu du nord alors hall
disait première journée de ce protocole
sanitaire allégé dans les écoles garder
le plus possible de place et des call
ouverte
c'est le bon cap selon vous alain
palausse effectivement il faut que les
élèves et les enfants puissent aller à
l'école le plus possible on s'est
retrouvé trop éloigné de l'école pour
beaucoup d'enfants pendant presque six
mois donc que les écoles restent
ouvertes oui maintenant à quelles
conditions
si on veut effectivement que les enfants
puissent bénéficier ou de polarité
satisfaisante qu'ils puissent continuer
à apprendre et rattraper le
éventuellement le retard qu'ils ont pu
avoir depuis depuis 13 mars
il faut s'en donner les moyens et dans
la l'impression que là le protocole s'il
cherche plutôt l inverse il faut ouvrir
coûte que coûte quitte à ce que le virus
se continue de se propager que des
enfants soient contaminés et surtout que
il le ramène à la maison et c'est
peut-être qui nous inquiète le plus
heavy de bois c'est ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui on nous coûte que coûte
finalement sans faire attention
réellement au protocole on ça passe en
second plan c'est comme ça vous voyez la
situation également n'ont absolument pas
on a un ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel bancaire qui est
justement ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui fait tout pour que tous
les enfants puissent avoir accès à
l'école donc il est parfaitement normal
si vous voulez qu'on allège le protocole
sanitaire afin de permettre à tous les
enfants de pouvoir bénéficier d'un
enseignement dit il faut dire pendant le
confinement il ya plein d'enfants qui
ont été privés notamment d'écoles donc
égalité c'est quoi l'égalité c'est de
rouvrir au maximum ces écoles notamment
pour faire vivre l'école de la
république pour faits vous vivre l'une
des valeurs les plus fondamentales de
notre république c'est à dire l'accès à
tous à l'éducation donc jean-michel
blanquer a mis en place notamment tout
un tas de protocole a fourni des masques
aux enseignants a fourni du jet li drôle
que à hydro alcooliques dans nos classes
et tout est réunit maintenant pour qu'on
puisse convenablement enseigner et pour
qu'on puisse notamment être à la hauteur
du défi qui nous attend
alors alain tu as le tout est réuni nous
sommes à la hauteur du défi qui nous
attend selon kevin beau ce faire vous
hochait la tête vous n'êtes pas d'accord
visiblement qu'est ce qui manque pour
vous je pensais pas je pense qu'on doit
pas enseignée dans le même domaine au
même ministère mais moi j'ai pas eu de
gel hydroalcoolique
j'ai eu cinq pauvres masquantes et en
textile qui sont aux normes depuis une
semaine qu'ils ne l'étaient pas et qui
ne sont ne peut pas enseigner avec je
suis désolé mais moi aussi je veux
absolument que les enfants mes enfants
que mes élèves puissent aller à l'école
novembre en commission
et pour ça je le redis il faut qu'on
s'en donne les moyens alors on nous dit
que les enfants ne sont pas contaminés
c'est faux c'est complètement faux les
chiffres qu'on a eu d'inspecteur
académique de dieu de lille la semaine
dernière mon que mercredi 6 117 cas sur
cinq cent quarante cinq mille enfants ça
veut dire à peu près un peu plus de 100
pour cent mille on est au dessus de la
moyenne nationale
on est un petit peu au dessus la moyenne
dans le département du nord 157
enseignants sur environ 30000 premier
second degré contaminées dans le
département du nord
on est à cinq cent pour cent mille je
veux bien qu'on me dise que le virus est
à sens unique que les enfants ne compte
elle ne se contaminent pas entre eux et
ne contaminent pas les enseignants les
parents mais c'est pas là c'est pas
c'est pas ça le virus continue de
circuler et les enfants entre eux
continuent de l'attraper donc
si on veut vraiment que les enfants
puissent continuer d à l'école parce que
je pense que là tu on se rejoint et
puisse continuer d'apprendre et c'est
une valeur fondamentale de la république
et nous y sommes attachés aux os ni pépé
il faut peut-être réfléchir à faire en
sorte que ces enfants puissent
bénéficier dans tout dans une forme de
sécurité sanitaire c'est à dire que
peut-être qu'il faut réduire les groupes
peut-être qu'il faut appliquer une
véritable distanciation sociale parce
que la halle est inapte et elle n'est
pas appliquée peut-être qu'effectivement
il faut que les enfants puissent se
laver les mains se nettoyer les mains
avec du cidre et du gel hydroalcoolique
et qu'ils soient fournis mais ce n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui
l'éducation nationale ne fournit pas de
gel hydro alcoolique mais j'en ai pas
dans ma classe et les points suivants
c'est ce qui est catastrophique c'est le
nombre d'enseignants le haut niveau du
concours on est passé dans l'académie de
lille 2700 pour premier second degré à
1000 milles 92 ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que à un moment donné on a besoin
de plus enseignants parce que les
enfants ont été privés d'école pendant
trop longtemps on diminue le nombre de
postes aux concours
on avait 700 postes dans l'académie de
lille en 2019 au concours de professeur
des écoles
il y en a 500 donc alors qu' on aurait
pu juste maintenir le nombre de postes
aux concours
ils sont baissé de 200 dans quelles
conditions les enfants vont ils être
accueillis et puis si on ajoute à ça le
problème de d'absence non remplacés qui
sont liées effectivement aussi au fait
que ben voilà dans le protocole
il ya des enseignants qui vont être
malade il faut qu'on puisse faire en
sorte que les actions soient remplacés
que les enfants puissent bénéficier de
la glace
là on en est loin alors kevin boss leur
vient d'entendre donc pas de gel
hydroalcoolique pas de matériel moines
professeurs selon alain talleux des
élèves qui se contaminent à
visiblement d'après ce qu'a constaté
alain talleux également qu'est ce que ça
veut ça donne vous dans les collèges et
les lycées
kevin bossuet n'y a pas de contamination
sur les jeunes écoutez moi je
contrairement à ce monsieur je ne suis
pas vivre je ne suis pas notamment
compétent pour savoir s'il ya des
contaminations pas il part notamment de
certains enseignants qui se sont
contaminées
ben moi j'aimerais bien savoir où donc
est longtemps notamment c'est dans nos
salles de classe qu'en sait-il je pense
que là il est typiquement dans un
discours idéologique dans un discours
politique où il est en train de mettre
en avant des revendications syndicales
en mélangeant tourner ni passé quand
même du protocole sanitaire à la baisse
du nombre de postes de professeurs à je
ne sais pas trop quoi donc voyez où on
est toujours dans ce petit syndicalisme
à la moelle moi le mieux qui n'a plus
aucune audience notamment dans la salle
des professeurs la vérité c'est que le
fsue n'a que le mot intérêts de l'élève
à la bouche et qu'au final il fait tout
pour que ces derniers ne puissent pas
bénéficier d'un enseignement normal la
vérité c'est qu'ils sont sans arrêt en
train de défendre ces syndicalistes
notamment le service public de
l'éducation et par leurs revendications
les extravagantes et leurs grèves à
répétition ils font tous notamment pour
que ce service public ne puisse pas
fonctionner la vérité c'est qu'il le
fsue pas son temps à se réclamer de la
république alors qu'il n'ose ils n'ont
de cesse il n'a de cesse de sacrifier
l'intérêt général sur l'autel de leurs
petites revendications syndicales et de
leur corporatisme ventripotent la vérité
c'est que ce syndicaliste n'est
absolument pas si vous voulez dans la
république il utilise notamment ses
élèves pour faire de la petite politique
puisque derrière ce qui est visé c'est
tva dimanche jean michel blanquer rc sa
politique et c'est aussi la politique d'
emmanuel macron je pense qu'il y en a
marre de ces idées au locle les
professeurs de terrain ne constate pas
ce que dit ce monsieur il y a en effet
dû gel hydroalcoolique dans nos salles
de classe il ya des masques qu'ils ont
fournis donc à un moment donné faut pas
quitté notamment les bureaux du snes et
quitter les de rodez du syndicat pour
aller un peu voir ce qui se passe dans
nos salles de classe
mon prêtre y en a marre de ces petites
c'est petit discours syndicaux qui
n'intéressent que ce qu'il est alain le
joug des neiges vous donne la réponse
sur ces reproches de sur le syndicalisme
sur le syndicaliste que vous représentez
quelle est votre réponse
alors la première chose c'est que sur
les chiffres ce ne sont pas mes chiffres
messieurs ce sont les chiffres de
l'inspecteur d'académie
donc je les invente pas c'est les
chiffres qui nous faudrait par
l'administration
donc voilà les chiffres du concours vous
pouvez les consulter sur le ministère
sur le site du ministère donc vous
constaterez aussi que c'est la même
chose
voilà donc ça c'est le premier point
deuxième point le ministère du
dictionnaire ne suis que sur nationale
ne fournit pas de gel hydroalcoolique
c'est faux alors peut-être que j'en
avais vu dans votre nom mais vous en
avez peut-être eu dans votre dans votre
établissement
mais ce n'est pas fournie par
l'établissement balance oui vous avez
bien ça montre des disparités messieurs
messieurs est ce que finalement ça ne
montre pas une disparité entre les
écoles allez-y je vous en prie sur le
syndicalisme le ventripotent jeu je le
remercie je vous remercie pour le pour
le compliment
donc je ne suis pas un syndicat
syndicaliste ventripotent je suis je
suis encore relativement svet je n'ai
pas besoin de vous montrer je suis en
classe monsieur j'enseigne auprès des
régies un cm1 cm2 chez 29 élèves
voilà donc je ne suis pas détaché et est
loin loin de la classe c'est faux je
suis enseignant depuis presque 20 ans et
je suis en classe depuis toujours
voilà ça c'est le point suivant et alors
par rapport au fait que je vous
représente rien je suis désolé monsieur
mais le style ni ppc 54 mille adhérents
sur 350 mille enseignants le premier
degré donc le jour où ils trouveraient
l'équivalent dans un parti politique
dans une quelconque syndicat la rodia
des syndicats qui sont très
représentatifs mais je crois que 54
mille enseignants pour 350 millions 54
mille enseignants syndiqués sur la
profession je pense que nous
représentons et je peux l'assumer nous
représentons le le premier degré et vous
pouvez dire ce que vous voulez mais
n'empêche qu'on à 54 mille personnes qui
tous les ans verse une cotisation et qui
nous suivent et qui nous accompagnent et
qui font partie et qui font le syndicat
est ce qu'il n'ya pas autant
d'organisations face à la crise du coc
vite 19 qui lie à autant
d'établissements kevin bossuet vous vous
avez donc du gel hydroalcoolique
visiblement vous êtes satisfait des
conditions dans lesquelles vous
travaillez ce qui n'est pas le cas
d'alain talleux effet finale finalement
est-ce que c'est pas le lier au chef de
l'établissement
est ce que chacun il va pas un petit peu
de sa formule au fond n'ont absolument
pas je crois qu'il ya un protocole
sanitaire qui est scrupuleusement
respectée vous savez moi je renseigne en
seine saint denis brun territoires
perdus de la
public pour reprendre cette expression
est dans nos établissements en
seine-saint-denis on a évidemment du gel
hydroalcoolique on a évidemment des
masses quant à la représentation
aujourd'hui du syndicalisme enseignant
c'est un petit peu n'importe quoi il
faut voir pourquoi les enseignants
adhère notamment un syndicat notamment
c'est pour essayer d'accélérer leur
mutation c'est pour faire en sorte si
vous voulez d'avoir des petites astuces
pour améliorer notamment leurs
conditions au niveau des mutations la
vérité c'est que dans l'enseignement
il ya seulement 20 à 25 % de taux de
syndicalisation ce qui fait que ce
monsieur le dit lui même il est
complètement minoritaires et ne
représentent pas notamment ses collègues
et dans un discours politique dans un
discours idéologique je pense qu'il
confond notamment sa salle des classes
avec une arène politique quand il ya un
enseignant responsable quand on à
l'intérêt général je liés au corps on
fait tout pour défendre notamment la
république qui ont fait tout pour
défendre l'accès à tous à l'éducation il
ya en seine-saint-denis quatre mille
enfants des enfants qui n'ont pas
retrouvé les salles de classe qui sont
complètement perdus ou sans ses enfants
pendant que monsieur est en train de
défendre notamment des petites
revendications syndicales des
enseignants sur les terrains et c'est
notamment d'aller récupérer ses enfants
voilà la république ses terres en sorte
que tout le monde puisse rentrer alors
certes il ya un risque sanitaire il est
minorée grâce au protocole qui est mise
en place
moi j'aimerais bien que ce monsieur
mettre le temps en avant l'intérêt de la
république l'intérêt général plutôt que
ces petites revendications syndicales
qui je le redis ne représente plus rien
en série des professeur alain pas le
pour vous le mot de la fin on le
rappelle quand même vous disiez ou au
début vous disiez quand même que
l'importance était tous les élèves un
puisse revenir dans les classes le mot
de la fin pour vous à lanta le oui
effectivement il faut que tous les
élèves dans les classes et d'ailleurs
c'est le cas moi j'ai mangé mes 29
élèves dans la glace donc je sais
effectivement quel droit où les enfants
font pas pu revenir mais c'est vrai
parce qu'à part d'enseignants tout
simplement et secret sait pas et c'est
pas la peau des enseignants c'est de la
faute du ministère qui n'a pas prévu que
les enseignants voilà donc ça c'est le
pont aussi peut-être sur lequel il
faudra terminer
et puis surtout moi je dirais que mes à
l'elysée une scolarité toute l'année je
voulais j'ai pas envie que ça s'arrête
encore une fois comme l'année dernière
parce que bat pour des raisons de
sanitaires ils pourront pas avoir classe
moi j'ai envie de pouvoir continuer à
faire classe avec eux en présentiel
parce que l'école école
et ça et la république c'est ça et je
suis un défenseur ardent de la
république
mais pour ça peut-être qu'il faut juste
juste penser à se donner les moyens de
scolariser les enfants correctement et
donc si c'est donner les moyens c'est
peut-être effectivement plus
d'enseignants plus de locaux pour
réduire le nombre de deux groupes pour
éviter la diffusion du virus
et puis effectivement quoi des masques
de qualité du gel hydroalcoolique dans
tous les établissements s'ils le font
etc etc et la bomba on attend toujours
et bien en tout cas un grand merci à
tous les deux d'avoir accepté le
principe du débat ce soir en direct sur
rt france merci à vous kevin bosse fait
je rappelle que vous êtes professeur
d'histoire en seine saint denis vous
nous l'avez dit merci à vous à linthal
le maître professeur et cosecrétaire
sweep fsu du nord et puis toujours en
france et nouvelles révélations autour
du cas de geneviève legay cette
militante de 73 ans blessé en mars 2019
à nice lors d'une intervention policière
et selon mediapart l'igpn parlerait
d'une disproportion de la charge
survenus pendant une manifestation des
gilets jaunes un nouveau rebondissement
dans une affaire déjà controversée le
président de la république lui-même
avait défendu une version policière
aujourd'hui a démenti thomas bonnin
c'est suffisamment rare pour être
soulignée l'igpn semble n'avoir eu
d'autre choix que de conclure à une
disproportion de l' usage de la force
par la police
tout part de ces images datées du 23
mars 2019 à nice lors d'une charge des
forces de l'ordre en direction d'un
petit groupe de manifestants
geneviève legay 73 ans drapeaux
pacifistes en un chute lourdement
elle sera hospitalisée avec des côtes
cassées et des fractures au niveau du
crâne
à l'époque la sphère fait grand bruit au
point qu emmanuel macron est invité à
réagir ces mots ne vont pas calmer les
esprits je souhaite d'abord qu'elle se
rétablisse au plus vite et sorte
rapidement de l'hôpital
je souhaite la quiétude à sa famille
mais pour avoir la quiétude
il faut avoir un comportement
responsable quand on est fragile qu'on
peut se faire bousculer on ne se rend
pas dans des lieux qui sont définies
comme interdit et on ne se met pas dans
des situations comme celle-ci pour les
manifestants le cas de geneviève le guen
ce qu'ils dénoncent depuis des mois un
usage parfois disproportionné de la
force lors du maintien de l'ordre en
manifestation cette thèse longtemps
réfutés par les autorités vient d'être
approuvé par l'igpn qui vise notamment
l'homme à la manoeuvre lors de cette
charge le commissaire divisionnaire
rabah souchi selon les éléments dévoilés
par mediapart qui cite l'igpn les ordres
donnés par le commissaire divisionnaire
sushis sont inadaptés en particulier
lors de la charge effectuée au cours de
laquelle madame le gars était poussé un
désaveu pour le commissaire
divisionnaire lui qui a défendu ses
agissements par une obligation de
résultat et par je cite une situation
qui se tendaient pour en attester le
commissaire fait état de manifestants
qui chantaient la marseillaise et
refusaient de quitter les lieux
une caractérisation de tension
croissante qui ne semble pas partagée
par un capitaine de gendarmerie dans ce
rapport dévoilé par mediapart
rabah souchi est présenté comme
particulièrement nerveux notamment parce
que le capitaine de gendarmerie en
question refuse de lancer une charge
contre une foule qu'il qualifie de calme
il indique à son collaborateur proche de
lui qu un capitaine de gendarmerie
refuse ses ordres je ne dis rien je n'ai
pas envie de me confronter à un individu
qui ne se maîtrisent plus et qui devient
même presque dangereux dans ce même
rapport le capitaine de gendarmerie
revient sur la charge des policiers
qu'ils observent de près lui aussi parle
de disproportion la charge est effectué
dans les conditions que vous avez pu
voir sur les différentes chaînes
télévisées d'information en totale
disproportion est nécessité face à une
foule d'une trentaine de personnes assez
âgées très calme avec de nombreux
journalistes
pas de gaz lacrymogène des sommations
d'emploi de la force uniquement et une
charge commandé par lui-même instantanée
brutale et violente qui occasionnera
l'incident que vous connaissez nous
sommes tous abasourdis
face à tant d'éléments l'igpn ne pouvait
que conclure à une disproportion
manifeste de la charge qui a blessé et
geneviève le guet une conclusion qui
intervient après plusieurs mois de
controverses autour de ce dossier
puisque le procureur de la république de
nice à venice
confiez l'enquète hélène pedroia qui non
seulement avait participé à l'opération
de maintien de l'ordre ce jour là et qui
se trouve en plus être la compagne du
commissaire divisionnaire rabah souchi
de quoi ajouter un peu plus de confusion
dans cette affaire devenue très
politique
reste à voir maintenant quelles seront
les suites pour le commissaire
divisionnaire rabah souchi qui avait été
décoré en juin 2019 par le ministre de
l'intérieur lors d'une promotion
surnommé promotion gilet jaune et pour
en parler nous sommes justement avec
geneviève le guen militante date avec
geneviève legay merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors la
conclusion la police des polices révélée
par mediapart vous l'accueillez on
imagine avec soulagement
j'ai pas compris votre question on
imagine que vous accueillez la nouvelle
avec soulagement les révélations de
mediapart comme quoi la police des
polices finalement reconnaît une charge
disproportionnée des forces de police
vous l'accueillez avec soulagement ce
soir soulagement c'est pas le mot ça me
met un peu de baume au coeur je pense
que richie pn ne pourrait pas faire à
moindre parce que franchement il ya
plein de il ya plein de témoignages
autour de 2 ce qui s'est passé est bon
bien sûr quand on vous l'avait dit le
rapport de gendarmerie de pointe bien la
disproportion puisque il se passe est
absolument rien j'ai entendu dans vos
commencé dans vos commentaires
quelques chanteurs marseillaise je pas
entendu coûté à part moi qui criaient
liberté de manifester et qui était sur
le point de partir je pense qu'il se
passe est absolument rien absolument
rien alors un an et demi nécessaires
pour arriver à cette conclusion
c'est trop long vous avez le sentiment
de ne pas avoir été reconnue comme une
victime
je pars je pense que les gpn ne voulait
pas reconnaître ça mais que dernièrement
il ya eu beaucoup de manifestations
contre les violences policières entame
un raciste mais aussi les autres donc
quand j'ai vu ces manifestations j'ai
pensé que le gipn ne pourrait pas ne
pouvez pas dire qu'il y avait pas de
violences policières d'abord dans mon
cas donc c'est arrivé c'est arrivé hier
ils ont ils ont fait que leur travail un
bon on va pas les féliciter maintenant
est ce que la justice va suivre on va
voir
justement qu'est ce que vous attendez
maintenant très concrètement alors déjà
il faut savoir que mon combat c'est pas
le combat de genia burgess et le sait le
combat de tous ceux qui luttent
notamment régis légende mais aussi tous
les autres les syndicats aussi et donc
ce procès j'espère qu'il va être un
membre un bon gros c'est quand qu'on va
gagner et pour justement redonner de
l'espoir dans cette france qui en ce
moment
voilà juge mal par exemple 7 septembre à
nice il ya des camarades des citoyens
dans une manifestation syndicales ont
crié à bas à bas les condés ce qu'on dit
depuis 1968
et pour ça ils ont pris trois ont pris
deux mois de prison avec sursis et un
collègue prof de maths a pris six mois
de prison avec sursis alors savez la
justice j'y croyais mais j'y crois de
moins en moins donc j'espère que ce
procès sera exemplaire
comment est ce que vous allez
aujourd'hui vous avez encore de
séquelles
ah oui bien sûr j'ai alors j'ai toujours
zéro doha j'ai je ne vois pas bien comme
il faut donc ce qui me fait marcher un
peu de travers j'ai pensé que le goût
salé sucré et j'ai de la pente au smi la
pente au smi s'est depuis juin depuis mi
juin 2019 donc ça fait 15 mois que 24
heures sur 24 g j'ai une hauteur qui
tourne qui tourne dans le nez et c'est
le cerveau d'après le neurologue c'est
le cerveau qui envoie une fausse
information
donc il faut vivre avec 24 heures sur 24
avec une odeur qui tourne tout en
n'ayant pas tout à fait un pas de doha
scléro est-ce que vous
considéré aujourd'hui comme un symbole
de la lutte contre les violences
policières geneviève le guet alors moi
je ne considère pas mais c'est vrai que
les gens autour de moi j'avais j'avais
un peu oublié ça avec le confinement
mais dès que des combats étaient des
confiné et que je me présente quelque
part des gens me voient comme un combat
comme un symbole comme une icône je ne
veux pas y échapper un donc je vous ai
pas parlé au niveau santé de mon côté
psychologique mais à partir de gouttes
l'année dernière j'ai dû aller chez le
psy parce que justement c'était trop
commandé les gens étaient bienveillants
sur ma santé sur le comment ça va se
passer le procès tout ça ils voient que
je gagne mais comme on répondait à une
personne de personnes ça va mais quand
on est confronté à des dizaines voire
des centaines de personnes c'est très
envahissant malgré que les personnes
soient guère brillante et donc et sarsat
repris après le confinement et et j'ai
fait un peu une dépression cet été je
vais un petit peu mieux mais voyez c'est
le passé du pour moi j'étais quelqu'un
de simple retrouvez-y comme c'est
difficile à accepter
surtout que j'ai rien fait de
particulier ce que je faisais depuis 45
ans descendent dans la rue pour détendre
et les libertés voilà vous demander des
droits
en tout cas un grand merci d'avoir
accepté ce soir de nous répondre en
direct sur rt france merci à vous que
geneviève leuglay je rappelle que vous
êtes militant d'attac et c'est la fin de
cette émission va se retrouver dans
quelques minutes pour faire un point
complet sur l'actualité
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
dans les bancs où la diversité c'est
notre point fort pas notre point faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs a
certes chohada et tout le monde discute
est finalement dumont discuter ils sont
trouvés entre le même drapeau libanais
pour une fois voyez des images assez
touchants de l'armée qui était presque
impliqué avec les manifestants
aujourd'hui on sent que le ton a changé
c'est la cause d un politique et sont en
train de manipuler l'armée on sait très
bien pourquoi ils nous tirent dessus
c'est pas s'ils savent que c'est leur
fin et se prépare